[Music]
hello happy Monday hi Joey
hello Joey's in here and I'm in here
there can only be one usually it's only
usually what's one of two things
usually it's overwatch but that's
actually tomorrow Halloween event will
be tomorrow we're gonna stream overwatch
tomorrow probably like when it's out but
by later in the afternoon because we
have another stream in the morning but I
have Unchained the so called resident
cuphead GameSpot expert Joey I'm gonna
go to the pip so you guys can see that
were playing cuphead let me switch it to
the other side too while we're at it
which means that as you can see in the
title we're gonna try to speed run what
i need to do is try to get this clock
here to adhere so hopefully i don't bust
the stream doing this if it does I
apologize and I probably should have
tested it sooner I really hope this
doesn't break it though for our sake
please we'll be okay please don't break
it okay there's our timer it is huge I'm
gonna shrink it where do you think I
should put it like above your head I
think it's fine I'm gonna do my work
we're not gonna do like a thing where we
like reset is just gonna see how long
it's gonna take Joey to beat this let me
preface this by saying that Joey has
200% of this game which means that he's
s-rank to everything if you don't know
how hard that is it's very hard
difficulties yeah obviously he's playing
on Xbox one now but he's also played on
PC right is that were you 200% it yeah
okay this one has one hundred seventy
three percent before I started over and
then anyway okay
all right here we go tell me when to hit
space just keep in mind this is the
first time I've ever attempted something
like yeah so you don't have optimal
routes this is just how fast can we
hopefully do it and we're not doing it
on expert right we're just gonna do this
to an unknown normal not simple but
normal all right you tell me when it
hits me
and okay let's go alright that was
slightly off but whatever we're not here
for like you know crazy crazy yeah but
yeah thank you guys all for tuning in we
are live every day at 11 a.m. today
stream I was just like Joey I need some
help
he's like I'll try to speedrun it I'm
like cool aspects no definitely not a
speedrun this is just a normal spirit
does it technically count where we
started it from when you create it would
you not like when it actually starts is
most speedrunners times I start before
this loading I think I think for
speedruns like official ones they
actually um they do something that
doesn't they don't know what's the word
for it
these pro strats I would have talked to
the kettle man they use like a specific
timer that gets rid of the loading
screens okay Modi in the game is kind of
inconsistent well yeah it's not always
long or not always short this yeah this
is arcane spot speedrun which is just
Joey trying to get through the game as
fast as possible not s-rank so basically
not expert and he's not worried about
the grade he's getting it's just be the
boss fast as possible but I when I'm in
YouTube twitch chat so you have
questions or concerns or comments for
Joey you know anything uplifting to tell
him clear eyes full hearts can't lose
running gun baby
now usually part of the strategy is to
just do running guns first right yeah
that way you said was one of the things
oh okay I think we're gonna be fine I
mean we have so much damage we can take
oh he's even pairing swag points oh my
god just kidding okay
oh how bad does he want it ladies Oh
number one death number one all right
it's going well it was how bad didn't
want that a coin
did you like need the coin yeah you need
the coins that's where all right so far
speedrun going well the other thing I
will preface is that I kind of threw
this at Joey last minute so he did not
have any time to like warm up either so
I'm gonna give him a slight out I'm
gonna give him a slight out that he did
not have time to warm up so technically
if he was to say Eric I want to start
over
I would totally give it to him but we'll
see how this this this run goes here
again let me preface that to everyone it
this is not like an official speedrun
it's just how well can we do right how
well can Joey do our resident expert you
said that the records like 36 37 37
minutes I believe is that full like you
have to kill every box right there yeah
like skipping or anything like that guys
do we need those coins oh man you
realize how oh you realize how crappy
like dash is compared to smoke Wow yeah
like it's crazy all right we got through
the first one no problem
do it alright bead not bad not bad I
mean we just wanted the coin so that's
that's all that mattered they're doing
three minutes in who says this should be
a piece of cake for you I don't know
when you do have a really speedrun
practice it's kind of not that easy out
it's you know like I've done so many
things like figuring out like optimal
stuff for bosses but you know I haven't
really like applied it look at this
sneaky-ass route I didn't even know you
could do that that's the first shortcut
in the game there's shortcuts in every
words as colonial noodles it says IP
ranked every level that's awesome yeah
that gets you that black and white yeah
it's incredibly hard oh that's this
level I I had to
I don't know if you get the feeling
we're like we just like I have to get
that coin yeah I kept doing this stupid
run because of the first coin and it
would just bother me so much I also did
I also was really bothered by not
getting through Perry's so I kept
reading yeah that's where you go back to
you like all day Angus has three chances
to do that for those of you who haven't
played too much cupcake I would say one
of the keys here is potentially
remapping your your set up it's looking
good right now guys looking really good
and good like I said this is all part of
the warm-up it's not going super hot you
know but uh yeah I think I think things
will get better
one can hope you see like I haven't
perfected that one do you like up Harry
I always I always miss it so it's easier
for me to like down Perry than it is for
me to up Kerry because it's like things
are yeah if it's coming in like full
speed in the opposite direction a little
bit Rakim 81 this is cuphead a new a
running gun platformer I guess or like I
forget exactly terminology that they use
but it's a it's very difficult you only
get three lives per level there are
potion there is a potion that lets you
like get one more yeah I think that's
like I'm guessing that's only like once
right I got one one-time thing like you
don't keep that right obviously you have
to keep it you get so you have four
throughout the game you can have up to
four it's one of the UH like the buffs
you can choose oh okay gotcha I haven't
gotten super far then I'm only on the
second world and I'm on the dragon who
apparently is a pain that the D oh yeah
the real crap dude
oh this boss is that I have a good story
for this boss too I after I beat him I
didn't realize what I had to do so I
went all the way back and then so what
you got to go to the right I'm like
ho-oh and I took damage - so my level my
four hearts is a trap says Marcel Hearn
I could see that
whoa whoa I always have to adjust for
that like Hadouken like a little like
pushy
that wasn't Oh awesome losing time here
I was gonna go and time and okay so the
one thing I do know that you have to do
is you need to have like at least one
extra piece of Health for that part yeah
just so you can actually you can
circumvent the boss if you just trying
to do pro strats before even testing
them I've seen it done that that's about
as far as I could I'll get alright so as
mentioned we are attempting it's not for
like world I mean like it'd be nice if
we beat the world record but we're
definitely not doing that it's not gonna
happen the first try is this game on PC
yes
Scooby two-four-six-eight $20.00 on
Steam also on Xbox one
not on ps4 though definitely worth it
that's $20 you'll ever spend Wow look at
this guy
the salesman and call you Joey the
salesman I think it's a solid game
though if you like this kind of game
though it can be a very frustrating game
yeah so I would say know what you're
getting yourself into before you spend
that money because you could potentially
regret because it is a very hard game
it's not that forgiving I will say
though when you make mistakes it's not
because the game cheated you is because
you actually made the mistakes so it's
like a fair game it's like kind of like
Dark Souls II right we're like you know
what you're getting yourself into you
have all the tools in the world to beat
these bosses beat these levels it's just
up to you to master them so you can't do
that trick you're talking yeah right
fortunately that's fine
deal with it there is also co-op mode in
this some people like it some people
don't
I know that John Luke has told me that
on running gun levels it's actually
harder he feels like with uh we should
just start over no this is why just from
like the way beginning all right here
I'm giving you one reset I'm giving you
one full reset if you want it I'm
willing to give you one full reset cuz I
wanted it's eight minutes yeah okay
we're gonna okay time out everyone
Eric's giving him the one continue in
his life I'm gonna stop the clock I'm
gonna start over you know we're good
we're gonna start over yeah yeah yeah
we're gonna start over - I was fine
right
I want one good run no it's not no faith
goop I'm trying to elevate his stats I'm
trying to give him better statistics
this is fine you want you over and and
it allowed more people to come into the
stream and now they understand what
we're doing so alright we're good we're
good
it is a stressful game Marko especially
when you're trying to speedrun it it's
already a stressful game when you're not
yeah like I'm stressed out playing it so
you know like Dark Souls meets Tom and
Jerry yeah a few songs I say 1 3 2 1 go
alright we're counting load screens so
if you see there's extra time there's
extra time it's fine it's fine
I gave them an 8 minute warm-up just
look at it that way can I get a do-over
for my life I don't know I mean you can
always start afresh it's totally up to
you now there's certain move to the
countryside
yeah there's certain ooh there's certain
things you might not be able to change
about your life but there are definitely
things other things you can you know
your health you know you could try to
you know like enhance your life with
more exercise eating better
you could strive for better jobs get a
study more get better education by
studying or reading more level up level
up you can level up in life you just
have to you got to put in the work to
level up though why you guys not co-op
in it because that would be the worst
run ever good luck on the second attempt
this elevator thank you yeah like we
think coffee drugs would be
pressive honestly for this game I bet
you still have that I bet I wouldn't be
shocked if speedrunners yeah you like a
classy I'm like a gdq or something
exactly more like Dark Souls on steroids
oh man dreamer game let's say but this
is this is less forgiving though in the
sense that you have you're constrained
by your life yeah like Dark Souls where
you can actually level up so I will give
you that he already reset yeah don't
worry this is the only reset he's
getting I promise you I'll make it worth
it don't worry oh god pact with him a
Blood Pact we are spare time later
Andrew was andrew leesia lee-sia
sorry if i put your last name i will
co-op with him but after the speedrun i
want to see him do it okay okay it's
okay okay this is gonna be hilarious
don't make me we'll be fine fine I know
I'm just nervous for you okay okay sorry
what silent their hand it was getting
sketchy you need to go you need to be
faster than 29 is is that the new record
that's okay yeah it's probably down
quite a bit
me is 20 I am crazy this is so much
louder than that yeah I think there's
something you to it just like the sound
effects like the results can be oh this
is unlikely to make an aid why is that
actually true I don't know if that's
true or not I'm not gonna read that
because what if that's wrong we are not
going for pacifist we're just trying to
get through the game as fast as possible
it doesn't matter what grades
just get it and just beat it and this is
normal
we're not doing expert even though as I
had mentioned Joey has s ranked the
whole game 200% which I still find weird
that you don't get anything other than
being able to say that you 200% yeah I
guess Oh a 29 was only bosses I think
okay yeah yeah no that's the smart
tactic see that's the other great thing
about this game is a if you know you
screwed up and you're starting off bad
you might as well just hit that retry
button right away no load no point
messing around you know unless you feel
like you're gonna be able to perfect the
rest of the run but I find that usually
it's it's best to kind of just start
fresh yeah we do know that you got three
lives hopefully you get farther before
you lose your first first heart their
[Music]
game submissions close to two three
weeks ago so zero people had runs to sum
all that sucks oh [ __ ] you're good
you're good just guys stay calm we're
gonna need that smoke a set I know yeah
we need it we definitely need smoke
smoke bomb and then the charge charge
weapon is like what you the two
definitely once again things so chips
coming out charge will do the most
damage at least until they nerf it
okay so sorry to cut you off there
Robert a13 jr. has kind of confirmed the
29 minute thing he said the fastest is
28 58 and that's everything everything
dancing we're looking for a nice 45 here
I don't know as I meant I said this kind
of before but I'm gonna say it again
we're playing cuphead we are a tempting
speedrun oh wow
go the dirty stuff alright there's a
time saver right there
but we're attempting speed run the 70s
Bernard cuphead Joey has never speed run
the game he's only played it like beat
it in terms of like all the stuff you
need to do yeah including me I'm pretty
familiar with with all the bosses so
we'll see how this goes
yeah so our hope is that we we hit a you
know be nice to hit us up like
30-something but remember
we have loading times I don't know if
the speedrunners are yeah I think like
they stopped the clock during one oh do
they exit and then come back in or
something so it's like they just when
the load times don't it just stops oh
the time stop okay
so poor crying it might be I don't see
if we get times because I think the
items here or oh wow you know smoke huh
I mean the first the first couple bosses
don't don't need it
thankfully the savage skip says Stephon
Myers that's right savage we got skips
that he's researched like before
probably are just seen on his way
through the game I know Joey Joey is the
the cup head spearheading the cup head
movement in the office what would you
say is the best potion you can use I
know it's definitely worth it okay
because like I usually have switch
weapon 2x okay which allows me to go
back and forth no not for this one the
charge you can't do this if you have to
hold it but like ill allow you to get
that extra like one one one frame or
something like one extra like like frame
of like damage from the other weapon
like super quick just so you guys know
if you guys don't know there's like a
weapon switch which to exploit egg may
be cool okay I guess that's very oh
that's it not hit
so I notice you're using the lock way
more than I do
I feel like I should probably be using I
don't think my nice job nice job I don't
think my uh my hands are used to like
all the buttons yet my muscle memory for
it is still kind of weird
I just refined the streets to tell our
trigger yeah which was like a huge
difference well yeah I think there could
be some some better potential there
Tom tp3 it says Joey said it's not
really a glitch it's just that people
are like quick swapping between the
weapons to let yeah like bit more you
mean mashing mashing switch so like it
almost seems like it'll there's like no
difference in speed in which they'll
shoot which is kind of weird that they
would that would be left in by guess
who's in time to switch the key Stefan
Myers bring a point that the original
Dark Souls had something similar with
frame timing during the weapon swap
animation did it hmm that's cool
charge beam ain't no joke as kkp silence
it's like right there you get when I
switch back in oh you're getting that
little optimism getting hit was not
optimal though so I don't know if you
guys are noticing that little purple bit
that's coming out but he's getting extra
bit of damage by doing the weapon swap
this is a cool boss yeah I know Michael
is having a little bit of difficulty the
first time but I feel like everyone runs
into like at least one boss that's just
their kryptonite and it's never the same
for yeah it's always like some people
get through it like super quickly other
people like you know took me like half
an hour
Lucas king of all says cuff hat chippy
on switch yeah I've to be a pretty good
one I feel like
[Music]
look at the patients on this man
[Music]
this is more like Megaman please stop
comparing every hard game to Dark Souls
that's fair I don't disagree with you
that every game gets compared to Dark
Souls I don't know if it's like Megaman
though cuz Megaman was pretty like I
mean like it tasted like the gameplay
style I could see why you think that but
then like in terms of like the
difficulty Megaman just in the sense
that like you have a life bar you have
like e tanks yeah things like that so
like the boss fights weren't as like as
like extensive I guess yeah and
especially like once you figure out like
what their counter weapon is it's like
they don't come like a joke assuming you
do like the order right well like like
the charge weapon though that's that's
pretty make that straight Mega Man yeah
I will say that I should stop using the
souls reference because it happens to a
lot of other games and it's not
necessarily fair to them if anything it
kind of reminds me of contra yeah
reminds me like a contra so I don't know
if it's worth it to get this but I'm
gonna do it anyway this is where the you
find first super nutty says knowing that
the final boss is harder than the
freaking queen bee scares me oh this is
just a parry level right just to get the
the first Super so it's a little slow no
I think I skipped this on accident we go
back I did it in the second world I
didn't even realize you don't have the
first super weird like oh well yeah the
tornado yeah yeah the second super
didn't seem that good and yeah I think
that one's probably better because it
allows me oh yeah it'll pull for speed
right okay gotcha guys cuz you can skips
what do you need this I don't know
you're just doing it it's doing it
anyway just because that's also feral
idea I could just say that this is a
hard game that has no relation to start
souls that's true I just think that I do
that thing where you try to describe a
game to people and you're trying to
relate it to other games you have played
I heard this is like another big game
for the FTC people - they're enjoying it
as well as it's like I don't know if
it's fair for me to keep bouncing around
different game types but it's one of
those things where you're trying to
explain it to somebody
like the easiest ways like you start
relating it to other games yeah which ya
probably shouldn't just throw out just
because it's hard that it's like Dark
Souls but I think contra is good a good
comparison though just like the style
and like the difficulty Dark Souls is
not hard that contra classic Mega Man I
don't any better I guess compared to the
pair to them I heard oh gee I don't want
to get into it did you guys know cuphead
has planned DLC that's live in Kent yeah
they've talked about wanting to do that
like there's more bosses as like a pack
o that'd be sick like just like another
like a little mini world yeah just like
yeah at an island he'll be really cool
neo is Dark Souls for sure
but then that did the devs nerve to
charge shot yet they said they were
going to okay
like they how do they know this thing's
broken I'm just kidding I shouldn't
throw out terms like that either it's
gonna cause rate they know it's a little
bit unbalanced relative to everything
else are they talking anything damn what
a stud I know I only took one of those
because I was afraid to grab the other
two
nice
oh yeah the duck don't forget about the
duck y'all damn he's real man that
damage is real all right so far we doing
a lot better we're almost done with like
the first world right I feel like and
we're at 12 minutes so yeah 13 minutes
counting loads so it's a little bit
behind I guess
what's up Zack attack Cee 7/5 yeah you
can feel free to keep commenting and if
you got some good points we'll bring it
up
yeah Gucci riot brings up a good point
there Souls is just a way for quickly or
saying it's hard I guess you know people
know that the history of that game I
guess Logan Kent thank you he says
you're welcome
is there because I don't I'm not sure is
there um is this gonna be like more than
one cup head is there like or have they
only talked about dlc only deal see it
okay like I can't imagine them doing
like another one like a full another
game within the next like a year or so
it's gonna be a while nutty asking
what's your hardest boss yeah what is
the hardest boss in your opinion sans
the devil okay
[Music]
think I would say that okay the dragon
boss is
I know def very difficult for a lot of
people there's a boss in world sir I
don't know if you want spoilers but
there's a boss in world three were you
we're gonna see it though
yeah there's a boss in world three that
is not kind
okay it's it's a flying level and it's
like a huge robot and like will wreck
you like oh I think I know which one the
old man and like that last phase is like
I've done it so many times do you think
that King dice is harder than okay yeah
keep this because it could be right yeah
well random list there right yeah I
think I had more frustration with that
with the robot
yeah mister me and Neil Howe says yeah
the scientist is the worse for them no
hope mr. mill oh I think I'm sorry if
that's wrong Tom Tom thinks that they
might catch out the weapon switching
thing to you yeah I'm sure they will
[Music]
before one four zero seven zero this is
cuphead if you've never seen it before
fun funfun a difficult game but very
rewarding it does give you the feeling
where like you know when you do it right
it's like it feels really good when you
beat a boss I've had a couple people in
the office Michael Hardy included we're
like you see them finally beautiful and
a slot machine
Prague's FM several times like
jubilation the carnival guy got me for a
while that the Train guy that guy's a
piece of crap dude that one's tough that
guy's fun though
like once you once you get it you're
like no worry Andrews just watch
he says the stream is lips but sadly
can't watch it all kind of spoilers yeah
if you're worried about spoilers we're
still in the first world so if you're
worried about spoilers obviously and you
want to experience it yourself just tune
out when you want to but really do you
appreciate you guys hanging out you
haven't hit that follow button on Twitch
go ahead and do that so you get notified
and if you haven't hit that sub button
on YouTube that'll also notify you when
we go live also
we're cool things like Joey's done a
bunch of different features on cuphead
as well as just showing you guys s
ranked expert mode gameplay you can
check that out that's on our YouTube
channel and he has other tips and tricks
videos as well so if you're keen on that
I would check that out just quickly go
Logan Kent's comment about King dices
cards yes like at the very end you have
to like jump and carry like a set of
cards that he like walks across the
stage oh I think it's how you doing and
like the hitbox for those is so is kind
of wonky almost mmm like the UM you'll
have to avoid getting hit by like the
regular cards on the side of them and
sometimes you'll have to parry I think
the parry hitbox is like in the middle
of the card so it's like it's come
you're not what you think it would be
after playing the game for so long bar
coid I've been told the world record
currently is like 28:58
which is pretty insane oh nice all that
stupid thing is anyway no no okay good
you're good maybe
[Music]
well this is so stressful all right okay
every time he has one life is very
stressful
Sam we got a bunch of moderators in chat
there should be uh we got a couple
people on office checking it out but do
you appreciate you offering sorry about
that guys
yes I'm in Austin also echoing that the
dragon guy in world 2 is hard I'm stuck
on that boss currently I haven't thrown
that much time into him but it's just
that his phases are more annoying and
maybe it's just that I'm not used to
that boss type yet what's going on
although scrolling thing the fire stuff
in the second part really gets me
because like you have to be like at a
certain angle that you don't like if
you're too high yeah shoots over them so
and they can't be too low so all right
boom all right not bad 18 minutes into
the second world I remember beating in
like an hour or two and I felt really
good I do like how the how they kind of
slowly ramp up the difficulty yeah like
I thought world one I was like oh you
know this games not bad I think I'm very
doable and then world twos like oh you
know what it's gonna these boss fights
are gonna be a little longer and a
little hard a little bit more depth yeah
Brandon Krauss are you asking why aren't
you using super spy because the damage
from your other side the the charge shot
will I feel like it's a little bit
higher DPS than using a super but I can
use a super in like certain situations
when I'm trying to like avoid damage
maybe yeah it's a little intense I got
an invulnerability kind of yeah yeah
it's easy to get
GameStop and GameSpot mixed up Zach I
get it at least you're not being one of
the few trolls I get through the chat I
think some people actually just
legitimately don't know but we don't
sell games we review games we do news on
games we do features on games this
process was kind of tough for me in the
beginning - I kind of had to see each of
the candies she threw out and then I
started getting used to it
lovebirds pretty good music Spanky's I
don't think talking up about it yeah
this song is great so I guess in that
case I was not mad to be losing gumball
oh that's not fair
do you know how long it took me to kill
that thing normal shooter because I just
didn't know what to do against him oh
yeah that's right
nice dog so you do have some
invulnerability frames I guess I can
tell cuz like when I must have missed
been missed timing it when I was using
it but like it was like I just saw you
go through the head yeah it's like
really close I've gone back to some
footage of myself playing and like
sometimes like especially during the
airplane stage it's like your hitbox can
change kind of weirdly like when you
when you shrink to the small plane like
your hip box trinks quite a bit yeah
Booton what's up welcome to the chat
yeah we're not pokey lord we're not
trying to beat the speed run the speed
run actually isn't even 40 minutes
anymore like it's a lot less 28:58
we're just trying to do a speed run and
we'll see how long it takes Joey
we don't even we're not even doing the
thing where we skip low times and stuff
this is just us playing through the game
as fast as we can just beating the boss
is beating the run and guns and I'm glad
you guys are here to tune in Joey made
sure to tell me before we started that
to make sure this wasn't in like an
official run and I was like nah dude
we're just trying we're just doing
attempts trying to see let him showcase
some of these skills and also just let
him play more cuphead because i think
he'll never argue about playing more cup
heads
do you feel like you need every coin I
would say so yes because like even with
every coin here like not not counting
the ones that you get like in the world
like you're gonna be left with like
they're so gonna be some items that you
can't buy yeah oh wow
did you dirty like do you want this coin
how bad do you want it you're being a
lot more patient than I because like I
remember I didn't even consider the
platform's really like falling off or
like worrying about that too much yeah
game that lock shot I don't use lock
shot enough either I feel like I should
be using that more I think at my binding
for it is like awful so it's very
unappealing for me to do the lock job
yeah I have it's like claw mode uh yeah
the keyboard controls aren't so so hot I
try putting controls yeah I try playing
on keyboard and it was not a good
experience I always say plug in that 360
controller if you have one or plug in a
xbox one controller or if you can and
you just have a ps4 I think you can just
do you might need to get like a program
to run ps4 on there but uh otherwise you
should be fine if you have the if you
have it on Steam you can it has like
native ps4 controller support which is
pretty awesome hmm
nutty asking what is your favorite charm
I personally haven't switched out of my
sponsor too good it's like it's probably
one that has the most applications yeah
but there are some other good ones for
like specific bosses like via the auto
parry works really well with the the
pirate boss yep loading yeah Logan Kent
just mentioned outlet I'll let you
finish it in a second but I spoke mom's
best but coffee is pretty good and P
sugar is great for mausoleums yes sorry
keep going
one the one of the charms that actually
did not start using till later was the
the whetstone which gives your Perry and
axe attack that's really good for like
you connect
jump on like smaller enemies and take
them out pretty easily
oh really yeah yeah ghosts babe
confirming ps4 controller works fine
Elijah also just saying you can use ps4
remote with program at ps4 yeah I've
used the s4 it's just whatever you
console you haven't have to like need oh
yes also the switch controller correct
yeah the pro controller that is a very
good call Zack attack and hey Dan at
1983 that is actually a clutch call that
thing feels good I remember buying mine
beating Zelda and then going like why do
I have this thing anymore and well you
you beat the entire thing without yeah I
played on I played on just handheld mode
almost like exclusively because I was
just playing in my bed and stuff like
that or on my couch while my girlfriend
was watching TV or you know I mean like
yes it's really fine Oh apparently King
Romney says you can use ps4 controller
on steam without program yeah better
okay so wait with the whetstone you can
jump on regular projectiles regular
enemies like in Harry to your first
Perry when you jump turns into an attack
so like if a small enemy is coming at
you you don't have like the the space to
shoot or some I think you can just
Imperium
sprinkle so here's the the weapon switch
in action yeah
[Music]
yeah like the the pro controller has
support for PC as well that was one of
the reasons why I bought it because I
was like oh maybe even if I don't use it
on a switch I'll eventually use it on PC
but I never ended up doing that I ended
up giving mice which are selling like
coca-cola to Jake at like a $5 discount
which I don't know why I did that but I
did see if I could survive with one
healthier I think I believe in you know
don't forget you're like why dodge right
whereas it bears you should not do it
I need a Perry actually killed it
are you killing no oh I think you
actually forgive her go again
[Music]
Oh what we try to close this time damn
that's lips rip that's the grip number
wine that's very good okay that's pretty
good I feel like that's pretty good he
was just a little um cavalier yeah I
accept reject the deck Elijah
it just sounds better when I tell you to
attempt to beat the record I'll change
it though I'll change it that's fair I
also
in hopes of coming close to the record
making me anytime
[Music]
how about that coming close to the
record all right let me change that
figure out across the board okay I think
that's fair right coming close I don't
know how close exactly
thanks man
yeah this boss is pretty annoying I
remember being like if you if you want a
good time with this you have to like get
you get like that okay
that's okay if we're doing does that
count yeah I hate this part
Experion job Street I guess you got a
wide there the only thing we're good
we're good
it's stupid mistakes that's all yeah
that's well like I said it that is part
of what makes this game fun if you're
into that kind of stuff just knowing
that you can restart it do it again
if you had the patience to do that
overcoming adversity
[Music]
Zach attack saying the only way for the
pro controller to work right now is to
have the program x36 ECE so you can
access the menu in levels did you just
oh okay that makes sense actually okay
well there you go there's a pro tip with
that one nutty saying a moment of
silence for the people who came into
this boss with no bullet hole experience
that's because a lot of I don't think
there's that many games nowadays that
have bullet holes but I remember that
[ __ ] was good I lost you don't realize
how bad you are in games as a kid until
you play games as an adult and you're
just like wow how did I make my dollar
last like an hour whereas like when I
was a kid I couldn't even make $10 or $5
last like half an hour dude I remember
playing a street fighter which alpha was
the one where you could get evil Ryu was
it - I don't remember it was either
alpha or alpha - Street Fighter and I
remember being at the arcade and I was
playing this guy that was playing as a
evil Ryu and he was demon raging the
[ __ ] out of me after a sweep and I never
realized that it was a throw until he
told me because he felt bad after I
wasted like three bucks kind of trying
to beat him and that I never came close
but he kept demon raging me and I was
like that is so cool well I don't just
you always like he's like I want to be I
want to figure out how to do that yeah
and then at some point the guy was just
like you got a job I'm like oh oh a plus
yeah that's why we died so much it was
to get a plus I right
oh my god the nickel arcades I used to
go to those all the time
pewter Dobby DLC before there's a cup
head two bumbling fans a Kotak what
about pac-man the worst bullet-hell
experience couldn't get past this okay
so the mausoleum to present the
invincibility so I think it might be
useful to grab this one Bob Jones arcade
games were team nt4 and x-men weren't
those the quarter hogs
yeah I liked Adam not know not children
be I'm like one of them doesn't have
life and it's like timers life I feel
like maybe it was an x-men that no II
don't dragon about it
yeah that's like the BS like you can
stay alive for however long you want but
I'm still gonna kill you because you
spent too long yeah Tim T was good so is
yeah a VP was actually one of my
favorite oh [ __ ] one of my favorite
arcade games I got so lucky my like
family relatives my uncle he used to
work for Capcom oh yeah so there was a
Capcom in like Sunnyvale like way back
in the day or something like that and
like on the weekends when he had to go
back in for some reason like go wrap
something up to work we got to play like
the cab's for free so like I got to play
like Darkstalkers for free and I a VP
for free was it was the best feeling I
miss captain like the days of like
captain commando and my final fight
[Music]
yeah we get it we get it
you take my head off uh apparently Logan
can't saying that it's only good if you
want to do pacifists running guns yeah
which one oh the invincibility yeah it's
really helpful they're they're cold Rick
yeah who got that Szechuan sauce this
Saturday though huh
I heard they ran out people starting
riots over it or something like that
yeah I saw one video where the guys
jumped onto the McDonald's like counter
where they like you know you pay and
he's like I pack yeah we got some though
Micro Joe from are like pretty much our
sister site GameSpot universe was able
to get a get a hold of a sauce packet
and was able to try some of it with I
think Tony Wilson who's in our East
Coast office as well as Matt Ehling I
think the and then someone from I think
our Entertainment Tonight office so out
of the four people they all had some
with either I think Nuggets or fries and
I saw two thumbs up for liking the sauce
one kind of neutral and then one thumbs
down so whatever that mixed yeah I
wasn't able to get any that's alright I
will say there was like that like one
McDonald's that like was supposed to
have it and then like all of a sudden
just like like just like last minute
didn't get a shipment but like for some
reason people didn't realize they were
getting a shipment so they were like oh
so they drove like three four hours and
like there was nothing there
if you were a real Genie you get us out
of here
no problem ah yeah we're just going
through the speed started the loading
screen so that's definitely adding a
bunch of time to the run
now obviously speedrunners have that way
to kind of circumvent or stop the clock
when there's load screens and then
restart the clock also we don't have
like a timer of like Joey's bests where
we go like this is a grand time this is
like green time we're ahead by like
three minutes we don't have any of that
so we're just trying to get through you
know as fast as we can especially Joey
can rather I'm not doing anything severe
comments and kind of here for moral
support moral support yeah exactly
here's more bullet hole dude you you got
through that part pretty fast so at this
part
I had three hearts so I kind of just
yellowed him a bit and just accept the
fact that I was gonna get hit we're
gonna show you how to dodge and this
this guy gave me hell yeah he's super
mode oh I bet it was like those beams a
shoes from the forehead and the pyramids
go off at the same time oh really yeah
[Music]
I never had fun like me man I miss Robin
Williams dude imagine if he could have
played Zelda on switch rip oh we're at
35 minutes already
oh god Elijah I would say that the
Szechuan sauce probably doesn't
necessarily taste like it a Chinese
restaurant sucks like a probably closed
was it like ketchup mixed with teriyaki
apparently I'm like really basic it was
pretty dark sauce though I wasn't making
fun that like I bet you it's like really
close to like sweet and sour yeah that's
why I assumed when like people started
talking about I'm like don't they
already have something like this yeah
probably
what's up stream overlay Pro how are you
doing this might be my favorite song a
game I don't know who G Bay 99 is but
apparently I sound like them G Bay yeah
that person is a lot younger than me
that's for sure it's not a legitimate
speedrun try clock it's just like Joey's
personal time and how fast we can get
through it because we we don't have a
thing to stop the clock and whatnot
especially when the load times come up
so that the time you see right now is
with why you killed him that fast do
this charge weapon
I need this charge weapon in my life you
know how long I was holding a stupid pea
shooter for you're using for the entire
time I used it for this boss until I I
know I used a spread on that part I
think yes pretty good for you guys seem
pretty good cuz it's like on expert
you're gonna have a lot more dogs dog
balloons just flying everywhere good
luck with Pepe no he's already smashing
Pepe got the super to
this is Debbie right yeah cookie the
clown that feel the clown but your ones
in the chat if you hate clowns cuz I
hate clowns look at that no problem
Jesus only one baseball thrown at me
it's so so good
but how can a cup in a mug be bros they
look at the cupboard together Elijah to
pickle fish 96 says wait a second how
old are you you look twenty four at most
keep going keep the guesses come in chat
for both of us
yeah for both of us what do you think
Joey ages he's on the Left hold on to me
let me know well we've got a second here
Joey on the left guess his age Eric on
the right guess my age this is gonna be
a fun game it's a real fun game for one
hint I'm the younger one but not by much
Kanak three six seven damn I need this
gun yeah dude I need this guy - hi Mike
hi i'm michael says Joey's 19 tastes 22
Michael Jeff Bob Joe saying Eric's 31:26
- the guy on the left healed my nutty
nuts
Joey's 25 Eric's 28 that's early Gigi 17
and 18 you can't spot interns tastes 39
wow thanks good old me 23 and 23 let's
see 27 and 25 I like this this is fun
game so far
I don't even remember your I don't even
remember your age I have a general gist
has anyone said your age right yet no
okay so no one has said anything his age
right captain chasing air 28 Joey 27 no
a taste for Tony and Joe 1631 tell your
old I am your 70 I am 80 apparently
according to Cheyenne afarid er oh this
level really wrecks me real bad you'll
see me right here no damage
what point of damage now that you said
that jerk oh you got the smoke bomb
tonight
okay I had smoked one too so clearly ah
that's what you get for swagging no no I
was once your fan and now I am NOT some
what no I'm just kidding
56 76 24 28 I like some of these
outlandish Outland just guesses here oh
man he went from saying no damage to
potentially dying here this guy playing
the hell is safe now Oh God
you know got that swag anymore no but
seriously you need to maybe not die here
okay the lips the lips screwed me over
later Lego Sam 69 and 69 so Cedric turbo
69 SM what a ripe old the age of 69
David Hall Caine what's your worst boss
that's directed to him lot Oh ivy
and what happened to all that confidence
you had Joey cuphead showed you cuphead
showed you one Oh God
and so confidence are you guys
Highlanders immortals from the clan
MacLeod there can only be one in which
that means one of us is gonna die by the
end of the stream and one of us is gonna
get stronger have you not watched the
Highlander I have it okay so the way
Highlander works is like okay
it's whoever like gets the sword no it's
so you kill each other essentially and
like you like gain their power
essentially by doing it like lightning
comes down and then like you gain their
power so we'll have to see who wins that
fight I'm looking to gain Joey's cuphead
powers and then I'll be able to beat it
all right left already
right 22 no he said that he's the
younger one you gotta flip those numbers
26 and 25 I like that they're still
guessing 27 and 25 Liz says hey Diddy is
swag and Joey's golden crispy that's
pretty fair I like brown today too young
to know hi know what Highlander is I
just never watched it I understand about
a sword or something like that yeah 51
yeah nutty there's apparently a 28:58
speedrun is the world record so far
whereas we're at 41 minutes with load
times though okay with load times I
don't think anyone's got your 8 oh here
comes the dragon I don't think anyone
has anyone gotten your age right no
nobody's got scene nobody's gotten my
age right yet that's for sure oh wait no
yeah close someone was close to my
people some people were close to mine
but no one's gotten yours yet I'm 4
years old apparently according to Zach
attack wait wait wait captain je captain
how close is that where is Kevin right
there
well is this is this mine and this is
you yeah that's is that dead-on that's
set that off it's okay captain J if you
flipped it
if you flipped your numbers you would be
dead on and I'm gonna let chat figure
that part out themselves
and see if they understand you're wrong
goob I'm not 32 I actually don't know
how old you are either yeah
machine check Paul man I don't want to
be associated take Paul oh the tail see
that's why this is how they get you
you're staring at the dragon and then
this stupid tail comes up left young
right old wait who's on the right again
I on the right I'm on the right no it's
the other way around look at look at the
PIP oh I'm okay that's my bad then
captain Jay got it right from the
beginning yeah I've been looking I've
been basing it on my left in his right
so yeah okay oh and got a freebie there
okay yes captain Jay 100% got it right
okay okay use the lover here you're 33
what yeah it's like haven't you seen
those stupid Asian memes the ones we're
like we're good till about like 50 it's
like you know like I don't get really
tiny or something like yeah it's like
really young we're good we plateau we
plateau for like 40 years and then a 50
60 is when I turned into like an old man
with a cane yeah
so Joey 29 right yeah 30 next long damn
30 next month number I don't know man I
want to tell you this real talk
is that everything past 30 I feel like
if you're if you're doing things
physically or like lifting things
deserting it seemed to linger longer and
like you don't I don't have that I like
to say that I don't have that Wolverine
kind of like recovery speed anymore not
that I had had I never had Wolverine
recovery speed to begin with but I
definitely feel like I recovered sooner
at a younger age than I do now
feels like a lie
feels like a lot longer now things
persist longer than you want them to you
oh I was saying I was gonna say you're
doing really well
oh my god damn it okay
charge charge it is oh nice dodge who
this boss is gonna I can tell this was
you know really oh nice Eric what do you
think of a hat in time I've only seen
gameplay of it I think it's interesting
if you're if you like that kind of
gameplay I think someone makes a good
point that I kind of like the 2d art
style that they have more than the 3d
stuff that they should that is actually
in the game but when hangovers last two
days yeah they don't last two days but
it's not like where you can you can get
to the point where you have a hangover
anymore oh no at least for me I have a
hangover it sucks it lasts longer now -
it's not like we're like in the morning
you're like yeah I had a bottle of water
I'm good let's drink again it's like oh
god it's like 7 o'clock at night and I'm
still hungover
what is life no for me and like I think
it's just how I my body just reacts out
I'll get the hangover that night
headaches yeah like that now you put
like the next morning we'll be okay okay
all right world 3 yeah 5 minutes that's
with loading by the way pretty sure if
we haven't done this before that's true
who do you like better cuphead or hmong
man I'm more of a mug guy in general I
kind of like man you just put so much
more liquid into a mug well yeah well a
tumbler for example as a cup right those
are pretty big okay now we're getting
we're arguing about cup some man cup
versus mug cups and mugs going downtown
so if y'all didn't know man okay real
trippy I just had deja vu okay yep I
there was a time I dreamt about me and
Joey doing Cup head on a stream on a
Monday morning that's really weird to
think but here we are we're playing cop
head
Joey's personal speedrun we're not going
for the record or anything he's doing a
pretty solid job so far he's only died
like three
yeah oh no here we go this is fine this
is nutty favorite boss right here sue me
nut he's still here this policeman doing
police B things who he's got he's hurt
and then you got these really sad
looking B workers that depict what most
be life is like it's very misleading
those streams of honey you would think
that that would damage them I'd hate to
think how long this would take me
without the chart shot because you're
not even like in the next phase yet it
feels like oh you read in a book story
time actually beat her at this part
before she goes oh really I don't pay
her for yeah wasn't really we're playing
now
[Music]
good luck says didn't even hate it
didn't even need a Logan you just did it
no problem man rip good luck nutty says
I'm on her right now Jesus no problem I
guess no problem for resonate cuphead
GameSpot expert Joey who only got to see
on that somehow is that okay I didn't
Perry got hit like a cashew and there is
no super mono too good saying this game
is so hard yeah it definitely ramps up
I'm not even this far yet I'm on that
dragon that dragon life man
you are you cool spoilers cuz why oh wow
oh I don't care I don't care about
spoilers I really don't I mean like the
game is the game and you play through
them like I mean sure
seeing getting exposed to some of those
things it's kind of like
makes it easier but I don't think it
does I mean like yeah well you know some
mechanics pretty quickly when you die so
it's not like a huge spoiler to me I
guess I don't know why was this boy I
mean just saying like future bosses oh I
don't get it I've seen so many I saw you
playing the devil the other days and
you're like hey do you want to see this
next part it's pretty cool but you'll
get spoiled and I'm like maybe I should
wait maybe the devil can wait I I could
I could avoid seeing the devil I mean
like terms of boss mechanics I'll suffer
that plight when I get there I hate that
goddamn dragon says I guess to gaming or
I I game yeah it's kind of annoying I
just note I will say though I guess it
was spoiler in a way though because I
saw how Joey just dealt with the dragon
and I wasn't even approaching it that
way and I'm like oh that's so much
smarter like during that second phase
you were on the top cloud you're
shooting down at him instead of like I
always trying to that whole time I've
been trying to like shoot him from the
middle yeah which puts me in a lot more
danger from the stupid fire guy or guys
are like they're like really random like
Clayface all I wanted was Clayface in a
Batman movie I don't know how they'd
ever do it but anyway sorry I was off
topic damn one shot killed the brick
this is okay this is where I figured out
the or I found out the power of the
charged shot just like getting those
walls destroyed and like one you got
yeah well is that counting the little
purple switch no it was like okay it
seems like that jeez that's insane man I
better beat the game with charged shot
before they nerf it at least I can say I
did it like everyone else did it greener
this Cyclops
dude this is very uh I probably would
have fell down once already just
platforms are not very big
hold tight oh and you're gonna go for
the going and you would leave my cords
oh man how do you get a job at GameSpot
ask a Linoone it takes a little bit of
luck I would say that I said this last
time to a thing I would just continue to
look for job openings here it's CBS
Interactive is actually kind of like our
mother brand
I guess that owns us and just look for a
job and apply if you meet those criteria
also it helped to be know people in the
office obviously because we'll try
harder to get referrals puter asking do
you guys have a personal worst game of
the year sorry for bad english oh I
don't I haven't endeavored in a lot of
games so it's hard for me to pick a bad
one do you have a bad game of the air
fan a bad game of the year I don't think
I played very very many bad games
yeah we've been fortunate enough where
I've only played a few games
like I prayed basically if I only played
like really I put like three or four
games this year yeah like it like
legitimately played them right I played
Zelda
I played neo put the [ __ ] out of neo
play the [ __ ] out of Elda play the crap
out of destiny too and still I am
probably missing something in there
playing cuphead yeah but I just played
in doses injustice Oh and justice yeah
but some of that I didn't go too crazy I
play more mortal combat than interested
I just thought I'm a Marvel guy yeah so
I I'm but that it's in saying that I
haven't really played that much infinite
so I don't know I just want Dragonball
fight us fight s it oh you have to wait
for come soon yeah
Oh Super Mom where man are could be I
could see maybe that being I don't know
it's just like every other boy right
right you going back for the dlc in you
know probably not goop i haven't played
the third one someone asked what your
favorite boss isn't anything favorite
one I think I think mechanics-wise I
really like the the pirate boss it's
Kyle play next year but it's like
probably one my favorites to actually
like do well at
[Music]
look at that we got cheap smoke bomb is
there you just flies right there
anything you have game mechanics we
don't care we have game abilities
everyone's favorite boss is the mermaid
I know I haven't gone through all the
bosses like these are pretty cool like
mechanics-wise I really like I heard I
heard about this one that apparently if
you feed on simple you don't get the flu
get the cvn do the full in do yeah the
concept for this one's pretty cool I
actually when I heard about it was like
oh sick I haven't even got there yet
wow that's okay whoo geez oh this
faucets nasty Tom and Jerry reference
probably did this boss is insane and
tu-142 says it took him 12 hours average
every time it's pretty good I think he's
gonna take me at least that I'm gonna be
shocked if it takes me longer sometimes
I really struggle with certain
encounters I have to throw my head so
hard to bash my head into the table
until it's dead oh really we're only in
a three rib count goood that's pretty
good
yeah googas I mean I guess I could try
to well last time I tried with text up
get like froze the freed so I'm
definitely this is the best track in the
game system oh I see what the world is
music
thank all the now music it all three
cazali
oh that was cheap I guess you could have
you could have dodged that right no
actually like the super can be a little
risky because like you're like the
moment the super ends you can get hit so
you have to like be careful even though
it's like you're invincible while while
it's going off
dizzy d-22 use as hard as hell but I
love the beginning of the robot 1 the
robot one the robot one it's let's say
this world right yeah the ending to that
is like oh that might be one of the road
blocks of the speedrun it should be
after the reset it should be post reset
goob so he says to then do that yeah I
know one of them wants the dragon yeah
you yeah it's at least 2 or 3 I would
say it's always tier 2 but that's fine
all right I'd like to see someone beat
this with their toes speedrunning that
would be insane all right
pirate a dark vector saying now floral
fury is the best working dice you got I
love the flowers idle animation - oh
here's your favorite right yeah I like
this one because it was like so much
going on
[Music]
he pair those okay just reminds me of
Popeye Danny did you kill that squid in
one shot yeah it was borderline trivial
Joey but what this is a speedrun so you
should be trying oh I didn't even see
that cannonball go why yeah that one's
like pretty sneaky like I've died - that
one more than because I'm just watching
your hair is happy to see the ball come
Oh chips angry got a sore throat there
[Music]
once again it's sneaky sneaky oh I have
to take a little bit of damage so this
one you could duck right remember when I
was watching you play a dog I saw I was
like I don't know I didn't think of that
first I thought oh it's pink
let me parry it Oh what it did laid the
prestige rate Oh
all right the destiny news things that
Bob beyond just central
ah that's suck success you at least will
just be able to go full on iron banner
tomorrow then that's unfortunate
thanks for the news though there Bob I
appreciate it
I'll send it over to our news team now
and I also got I tell my raid groups
sorry this is cuphead I got derailed
kareem 347 is asking how many apparently
they died 1453 times on the first
playthrough how many times did you die
in your first gameplay I think mine I
took a screenshot of it when it when
they have a I was like three hundred and
forty-seven times which felt like a lot
I can't imagine what over a thousand
that's a thousand Kareem 347th 1,400
times I saw you uh do they get this fast
because the truth was in this stage that
tells you that you could do it oh that's
not good Oh 1 hp going to that last
thing
ideal alrighty I mean I'm probably gonna
die a lot
Oh goop said he only died like 200 times
but he said he restarted a lot yeah I
think like we're going by like that
sounds like play the level definitely
more than the amount of times I'm
topping yeah art as mentioned our
speedrun time is not gonna be as solid
as most return times because we don't
have we're counting the load times here
I haven't stopped the clock basically
since it started but Joey's getting
through there pretty pretty much like a
champ here
I wouldn't even come close to except
being able to do this he's only died and
you started going to be like once or
twice two or three times death maybe we
start the spread for this one look at
that green oh you had together huh did
you really I had to go with spread like
oh not good for this one rip
count it I want to count goob
is that mr. krabs it could be ah yeah
yeah I think it's actually a lobster I
think you're right man this sweater was
a mistake Joey I'm so no I probably
should some point you know I need
alright hold on guys I turn on the fan
in here it's getting out of control
[Music]
rip count for oh I forgot that
invincibility whatever you know no going
back I'm not so optimal man does they're
hitting Joe I know it's in the boat
[Music]
thank you for the tip though there Z kid
[Music]
it's just reminds me a contra give me
that s never want to be stuck with an L
man L was a freaking worst gun it's like
just please avoid the laser those are
crabs though yeah those are great yeah
and the neck a lobster yeah under the
sea we need a Justin he loves karaoke
under the sea that's like his thing just
take it off if you have a shirt under
that's true I could that's my next
optional idea but then I might break
Terms of Service just by lifting up my
sweater taking taking that off to get to
my shirt and then it's like oops
I showed some of my belly I could go
full game though
[Music]
who wouldn't needed that spread with
really any much JK guys we still got it
we've still got mad problems
he needs that invincibility and how did
you do this on pacifist I many tries Oh
No is this where we go sure we get held
up McNiff says clear TOS support yeah
that was because it was like his old
content new TOS says that you can't do
any of that but lobsters
they're everywhere all the types of
seafood you can eat burning bad this is
I think we're okay and what do you okay
I'm like I said I need the chase with
you like
I'm gonna look at the chat here are you
going to play co-op maybe we have time
nimble one but it's fine not gonna
happen I just want to see Joey get to do
this
screw the coin yeah yeah we don't need
it we got secret coin to destroy those
rocks there oh I keep wondering why you
keep going for that thing but it makes
sense that all right my TV literally
died the longest on this he's not even
going for coins anymore I just realize I
don't really need them well cuz you have
everything now I have everything that I
want all the tools that you would yeah
that you want to be the game rip coin
one now rip like several coins now
because Joey thinks he's locked and
loaded
oh that does it rule would be playing a
real risky play I like it how many
bosses you have up roughly a decade
okay I think we'll make it and it was
fun king Dyson the devil and I believe
we can't stop till the we can stop the
timer
I'm not we're not going out like that I
believe this chaplain put the ones in
chat if you think Joey's gonna do it in
the next Oh God
but to if you don't think he's gonna
make it
please don't yeah okay yes if you dashed
you might have died actually I probably
up knowing me I probably would have -
just because I was so - - right into the
book I leave the dog right there I would
have - oh honey like when I died the
first time on the stupid dragonfly that
means the screens gonna move over no we
made it through there about five bosses
ago I'm feeling good
do you have to do the running guns super
gross I'm guessing you don't have to oh
you don't
but like yeah I just I don't see if I
can get a hundred percent at at least
got it we'll see now I like it yes you
could die - the pearl is the power a lot
of two's just kidding Steamboat Mickey
yeah it's got that Steamboat Mickey vibe
that's what my girlfriend was shamed in
the - yesterday - and she's watching a
little bit she's like that's like
Steamboat Mickey my kind of scene but
Willy Steamboat Willie yeah sorry yeah
not so sure why so worried about King
dice you should give yeah I know I just
I was last weekend I was trying to be on
it come on the expert he has expert PTSD
is what he has right now he doesn't
realize he's playing normal I know it's
like here's the mermaid she's a siren
oh look at that
total cure white flag here I like that
it's nice little touch I like all the
subtle touches in the game yeah just
like the inmate it's like when you kill
like a just random enemies oh that looks
real fun I can't wait to do this level
I'm already dreading it taking so long
get your eels there we go don't worry by
oh just keep persisting you will
eventually find a way to beat said boss
there are a lot of tough ones like I'm
I'm gonna struggle on the dragon for a
bit I can already tell and that's in
world - so can you dodge that when you
have that defy I think you can dodge if
you go like all the way to the top but
like I said yeah but the coral like on
the top and bottom of the screen can
hurt you
oh so that's just an illusion yeah no
care all right look this is she was
easier than a running gun my wall siren
or mermaids a ceedric bears same thing
sirens and mermaids I thought they were
similar but maybe they're not the same
thing she's a mermaid sorry because I'm
what's a siren I'll have to look it up
the world best fitzy pipsy is like 28:58
is I think is what chat said what is a
siren or siren which is mermaid there's
a quiz siren has such sweet voices what
is the difference
oh there's okay a key difference no see
mermen a siren are mythical beautiful
female creatures which differ in their
appearance a mermaid is a half woman
half fish mythical creature while a
siren is a half woman half bird type
okay so it's that bird type bird it's a
bird woman instead of a fish woman
all right here we go this is actually
one of my favorite ones thanks uh oh
[ __ ] wrong weapon
whatever no charge I like I just like
the the layout of like this like however
like each space is like a different act
in a play do this eventually unless I
just beat it I feel like he could beat
it you just take longer this start the
first the first act where she gets
married goes off with her man what are
you gonna do with dice can well talk
about it when we get there
Sergio cross that bridge when get to it
all count done that I don't my smoke
bomb either fun yeah I took it off for
the off the airplane sages yeah
[Music]
oh that's a waste of a super guys
something yeah just one bar she turned
into a Gorgon ah siren I never said she
turned into a siren I made the mistake
of calling her a siren to which chat
then corrected me and telling me that
she's just a mermaid that turned into a
Gorgon and somebody okay yet I do not
know how to deal what did you say some
guy beat without using wait did someone
beat Oh without smoking he said it said
something like without dashing at all
like apparently it's possible to beat
the game like that how do you avoid that
guy I have no idea huh or maybe you just
take the damage and call it a day man I
like how fast retry is but it some of
these load times are kind of like yeah
we have chart shot he just happened to
swap out of it during that airplane
stage optimal we're back to optimal just
now we're suboptimal now we're optimal I
recount seven count seven hour ten we
got a couple more bosses to go again
this is just
Joey's personal speedrun I know at first
I put that we were gonna try to
challenge the speedrun that was not
correct terminology we were just trying
to do our best version of our speedrun I
have no idea what our time would be like
if we didn't have all the legs beat by a
lot faster look at that next thing is
already a lot faster but you took some
oh okay so people weren't chatter
telling me to get over the big wave you
can parry the star in the middle okay
thank you chat that was a bunch of
people my meal ho loking can good I was
always wondering what the point of the
star was I guess I just I always parried
it yes like Harriet yeah I really think
it's cool that there are other ways of
beating a level than just having to do
something so you're not pigeon holed
into using Pacific thing to like beat a
boss so he is using the charge shot
right now if you didn't see we are
currently playing on Xbox one but he has
on PC he sees where he 200 percent of it
is all the expert modes an s-rank this
is a 173 I think for anyone who has who
had played the game they might have
actually run into some save issues with
the Windows Store version oh I heard
about that yeah so apparently like there
were some bugs like re reverting
progress back like a save ago so
sometimes I would have I would play like
an hour's worth maybe be a couple bosses
then I would reload it and notice that
they were not completed or the score was
like an old one which is weird because
the achievements were we're still there
yeah you would get the achievement but
then it would just revert to the old
save and kind of sucks Michael I don't
think we have an Xbox one elite
controller in the office I think
I don't think we do so you might have to
get one fortunately what's up NFS I'm
gonna assume need for speed legend 23
what's up but he is name was NS and fs
legend 23 my favorite boss Z kid 1070 he
says by the way watching guys from
Maruti Asst I totally butchered that do
you know I say that oh here's the robot
the sky
oh [ __ ] remember when you say you want
to go for sub 30 that was I say that I
try that I was probably one that said
that how's the run going so far it's
going alright
I mean again as mentioned we have we
have load times so I am like again I
don't know what it's like did not have
the load times is it like what our times
are cut in half I have no idea I think
it's going pretty well he died like
mostly 2 1 1 in ground level I feel like
that was the biggest struggle so far but
he's been mostly one-shotting to shotty
losses again this is kind of like Joey's
personal speedrun
I shouldn't have prefaced it as a record
1 I didn't realize and he's never done a
speedrun actually like you never
legitimately cooked like fried or put in
the practice for it but he's doing
pretty well I feel like for his first go
I mean we get reset once like earlier he
didn't have warm-up sight I just said
you know that's your warm-up run we'll
start over better he finished the first
world in like 18 minutes or something
like that which is like pretty good that
was with low time so now we're at about
an hour 15 and we're like nearing the
end here we got to put more bosses plus
the final boss left yeah
you're brave for doing speed rescuing
also what you guys don't realize is he's
talking to us while playing so I've
gotten better at it because people keep
coming over to my desk yeah okay now
right now I would always just tell
people hey hold that thought
what's up David does stuff smiley face
what's up audio medic I guess that's
Lucy Oh we'll check it come back
tomorrow for some hot overwatch action
we'll be back at some point hopefully
early afternoon is what we're trying to
aim for we have a shadow war stream
tomorrow as well chastity will be on
there for the launch our review for that
it's also up done by Justin hey one
curious review for cup heads also been
up for a while down with Peter Brown
where you gave it a 9 right 8 8 that's
why I Joe is here to keep me in check
really for all your cup head knees
[Music]
alright get on train boss sorry to hear
that you're having a bug Bobby did you
ever have this bug Joey a bug with a
running gun treetop trouble it's
possible to a plus I think I've had like
some sport issues like I've beaten the
stage without any damage it should have
been s but ends up getting like a should
pick different weapon cheese low time
again optimal Saba woody alright the
hoodie comes off we were playing on a
gamepad oh my god I can't imagine
playing this on a keyboard
what's a pelipper that's pretty tough I
tried the other day it's pretty rough
you try yeah and then I quickly got a
controller okay spread here 42 saying
why are some bosses easy and so it like
pretty easy and wire some so hard
oops calling me out saying this boss is
pretty easy so you better get a dentist
one that's what he says I would well
let's he's trolling no angry Joe gave
this game with 10 out of 10 that's cool
I think some people to argument about
potentially why some people are not as
big of a fan of this game is just that
it is so hard and even though there is a
simple mode it doesn't allow you access
to the rest of the game so you're
actually missing out because you can't
play good I guess which for me I'm an
elitist so I'm like yeah the people that
beat the game the way it should be
beaten should get what they want but
that does that demographic has to be
small right yeah well except to everyone
else so I think it is kind of a little
unfortunate that people don't get to
experience the full game just because
maybe they're not the fastest you know
maybe they're which reflexes aren't as
great you know there's a flaw debate
Goyle yeah that's the debate that's one
of the big ones though so
what's up Jersey minor plays welcome to
scream thanks for tuning in we are doing
pretty well pelipper I think Joey's done
a pretty solid job so far we're almost
to the end here about our 18 minutes
count all the low times mister me miss
know my meal ho so this was easy for
them because they use the boomerang and
just kind of shot backwards the whole
time yeah boomerangs with those uh-huh
sixer 42 says as a casual I'm just happy
to watch others play and get frustrated
yeah then you kind of share that same
feeling right after I guess like I guess
that's how you can look at it I share
the same frustrations and struggles that
you're going through whoa oh is that the
admissable of yeah little bit extra
coverage on the end what's up max Reese
how are you doing hello Louise Oh 802
Tom tp3 says the time would be at least
10 minutes lower if you're on an SSD
probably probably uh yeah unfortunately
this is the Xbox version so a little bit
longer
yeah the art style is pretty great
Andrew art and the music it's been
pretty awesome a hand-drawn right yeah
all right are we going into the soil
we're going to casino Hill right now
all right casino he'll try our house
always wins
I just got back from Vegas the house
always telling you only so only like one
of my friends actually want money out of
like the six seven six of us they made
the deal with the devil dente probably
and then now he's probably out killing
or not killing good looking for looking
for people to get ransom like the money
bag he's collecting money King dice King
dice what's up FPS madness all right
final stretch here two bosses left right
yeah it's got in the devil
prepare for cards not for some cards you
Joey
so this is all random not random but you
can you choose how many spaces to move
by like hitting the dice it's like you
can you know which bosses are under each
number you can like kind of pick and
choose which ones you want to fight
three three four seven I almost quit at
dice King but didn't finish him quickly
Joey yup that's right don't make deals
with the devil is he a cigar that cigar
yeah okay so his death animation is
pretty cool
come on there we go
stomped out ant 21:42 says I asked my
friend do you have cuphead he says yes
then I asked him if cuphead is a casual
game he said yes
I now know he does not have cup head
it's pretty good test actually or maybe
he's really good maybe he's PC has
shorter load times uh says is Samri he
said that yeah I'm not shocked by that
the big guy was a cigar the floating
stuff with cigarettes all right what's
this one this one is a magic act so like
for King dices ba spells they're all
based off of what casino stuff or like
Vegas thing magic acts a casino I guess
you could consider the have like you
know like magic acts Criss Angel
Mindfreak thank David Blaine is pretty
cool
there we go
Joey is straight swagging I have one
more test oh yeah one more and then oh
yeah yeah see ah didn't get safe it's
fine I don't time for saving for going
safety let's go straight into the bosses
what happens if you go too safe
then you just roll again so you
technically you good right yeah but you
could safe your way uh I I gaming said
he's beat the game without smoke bomb
and it's a bloody nightmare I would not
want to live that life I was so good
it's like them hot dodge brain
invulnerability all about it so she is a
roulette table right I lost some money
playing the video video roulette yeah I
play some real roulette after video
roulette cheaper
you only have a three dollar minimum
where is like but I feel like it can be
more video really has the ball in the
middle yeah but yeah it could be you
just use the video like screen to bed
Jordan : saying you're good at this game
he is our resident expert if he can't do
it none of us can
okay now I'm safe what if you got start
over and you gotta go really back to the
beginning yeah and you got a roll again
one I dare you no thank you
oh here come those hot cards
I remember when I first played so your
life is for all the bosses and him yeah
oh my god I am so scared now be scared
about this I also have a super on deck
so he's right now ah freaking dice
someone said to skip the devil boss can
you actually even do that
can you legitimately skip the devil no I
mean if you do that's and then you don't
finish the game I guess Harry's on point
says goob there's some sick Perry's I
would have died three times over already
alright how are we doing on time uh we
have 124 so I feel like if you beat him
here you'll probably wrap it at 130 now
or 30 which is pretty solid
considering my times and everything I'm
kind of curious how much load times
contributed apparently you can choose
not to fight him oh yeah and then okay
so there's like an option at the very
end no we're gonna fight a little bit
now we're gonna kill him dude don't make
deals with the devil now kill him
otherwise other people it's all the same
thing let's you choose to join his like
his like posse or because you're so
strong he's like well oh look how far
you've come
I see you have my soul contracts that's
agreed hand him over and join my team
initially I my first playthrough this I
hit yes that was like oh the credits
rolled a second hey is that that bad
ending then yes the better just we're
getting the good engines yeah what's up
Jules Stewart welcome to the chat they
stopping by we are on the last boss of
our door not even as they are of joeys
personal speedrun we are at about an
hour 30 minutes with all the times but
this is a hundred percent so it's like
he did all the running guns - if we get
to an hour thirty I think it's pretty
good pretty solid I the personal best
apparently is 28:58 that's insane to me
yeah but still hey what prior to you
Joey I can't beat this game an hour and
a half that's for sure
here we go the devil is it go
nice thing
[Music]
what just happened
oh-oh-oh not like this Joey not like
this
do we just lose I don't know damn it
Xbox the devil wand the timer no I
should have stopped the timer no it's
fine fine fine keep going we must deal
with all see yes don't make a deal with
the devil the devil made a deal with
Xbox and Microsoft and crashed us I'm a
salty for you what just happened I don't
even know that like I said the devil
crashed our Xbox some hot garbage really
the devil's ten percent looks like yeah
that doesn't make sense either that math
doesn't make sense either do we miss
something
I really feel mausoleum is their
mausoleum and world 3oe there is I don't
know if we need to beat it though okay
it's fine I just don't want you don't
make me look like a liar when I said a
hundred percent rip well if it's not
then I can go but always go back in kid
all right
rematch I could see that Tom he says
that he feels like the smoke bomb kind
of ruin some of the bosses yeah a little
bit but hey you gotta use what the game
gives you the Xbox is a devil himself
that could be the temple is in the Xbox
I don't own one the devil is not in my
house that's all I know
gube said he had 93 percent before the
devil yeah it might be a mausoleum rip
get ps4 too bad this game is not on ps4
right now it was easier to bring the
Xbox one in than it was to bring his PC
yet so here we go I feel like he had a
good you're like you need me get hit
Yeah right yeah
good run what a run the devil knew you
were gonna win that's why
Oh getting all A's or P's give you a
hundred percent
I guess the devil's only four percent
okay so this will be a 94 percent run
then I guess close enough
load time is real yeah the load time is
definitely real an Xbox reserved and
that was creepy
[Music]
[Music]
oh he's a skeleton people saying you can
up it stand on there or something to
shoot down to a hole and skip this over
oh really
gonna do some cheesy stuff no I'm all
about oh yeah I'm all about that cheese
as long as it's not Swiss cheese because
you don't want cheese with holes in it
that's really bad
you need some eyedrops you're getting
Drive from you shooting them in the base
clear eyes full hearts Camrys let's have
a soup invincibility super on deck do
you think that's the best for the boss
yeah pretty sure he's gonna cry this
part right here we got stand on the one
platform shoot there you go oh is that
except you look Harry yeah yeah whatever
I can't area stop this thing I don't
know why stop when does it when does the
baby want the magazine I think it's more
credit I don't know could it should I I
think I should have been once to knock
out happen lost some time there one hour
30 that's that's not bad for the first
30 and we got the crash yeah this game
is called cuphead Pavelec Bielski are
you sure it doesn't count so after this
I I don't know I don't know that's fine
oh look you burned all your contract if
all those people you killed you don't
you don't even feel bad
you don't even feel bad they're bad
people right no they're actually I don't
know okay so the story with cuphead if
you guys haven't seen I skipped over it
in the beginning but like they kinda
McMahon they love gambling so they go to
the devil's to say like okay I I need
more money like the Devil Makes deal
with them oh if you win you get
everything in my casino you basically
have it but if you lose I take your
souls and then they lost so they're like
no they're trying to beg with them
please don't do this so like okay I'll
let you live if you go out and collect
the contracts for everyone other
basically every all the other bosses had
made a deal with the devil previously
and they're indebted to him so they he
had basically hires cuphead to he's a
contract killer
I guess he's [ __ ] yeah so they're not
bad people they were just there dude
just wanted to do them gamble they just
want to get Hey look they're all okay
yeah they're fine because they burn the
contracts and you're like you're you're
free you're all free now so until next
time look they're all so happy they were
so mean when you're fighting them yeah
this is awkward
who wouldn't new is all the devil's
fault as most of the time it is anyways
that was pretty good run Joey yeah I
think so hour and a half for Joey to
beat it with low times that one crash a
couple couple half a dozen deaths like
12 or something I don't know counting
restarts but thanks everyone for tuning
in we'll be back tomorrow 11:00 a.m.
shadow of war laundry stream and the me
and Joey will be back later that
afternoon probably around 1 or 2
hopefully they do some overwatch
Halloween event I'm not actually sure
when it comes out usually it's around 11
mm but we'll be back for that too
so come back and then Wednesday of
course we have the lobby but until next
time until tomorrow when we come back
and say hello goodbye for now have a
good day go bike up head right yeah go
good go yet anything else from you 200%
s-rank Joey just go buy it just play it
there you go try it enjoy it the music
the animation the bosses everything all
right I want to see you guys
[Music]